في 2022 وقعت الكثير من الاحداث غير
المسبوقه عالميا على جميع الاصعده
والجوانب الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
والرياضيه نستعرض بعضها في يناير اصبحت
ابل اول شركه تتجاوز قيمتها السوقيه ثلاثه
ريونات دولار لكنها تراجعت بعد ذلك بسبب
التضخم العالمي والاقتصاد غير المستقر
انهيار وجرف جلديه في القاره القطبيه
الجنوبيه اندرتيكر في منتصف مارس الماضي
وهو اول انهيار من نوعه بشرق القاره منذ
ان بدات الاقمار الاصطناعيه في
تسجيلها ايضا بيعه لوحه لوجه النجمه
الامريكيه مارلين مونرو مقابل
195 مليون دولار في مايو الماضي لتحطم
الرقم القياسيه المسجل في 2017 وتكون اغلى
عمل فني يباع في مزادا علني في اكتوبر
الماضي اصبح ريشي سوناك اول رئيس وزراء
بريطاني من اقليه عرقيه والاصغر في تاريخ
بريطانيا الحديث كذلك كاس العالم لاول مره
في الشرق الاوسط وفي دوله عربيه مونديال
قطر 2022 هو اول نسخه ايضا تقام فيه فصل
الشتاء وسجل حضور اول طاقم تحكيم نسائي
بالكامل تحديدا في مباراه كوستاريكا
والمانيا
[موسيقى]